[Music]
what about what about drinking in front
of your folks uh yeah yeah
yeah yeah see I'm from the I don't know
where you're from I'm from the soua
uhhuh that was a from 8th grade on I
think that was pretty okay well that
that was me I I used to never drink in
front of my parents and now you had a
wine thing I heard I did have a wine
thing that's real I would never lie and
it was white zendo you're bet oh
delicious it's the juice of wine oh can
I it's not B I mean it's not it's not
going to get you
laid no I can't drink beer anymore it
just makes me well it makes me
poop I'm not a f I'm not a fan of beer
no I don't I I used to like it I had
certain moods for it but cannot drink it
because of the poop just and that yeah
right through horrible beer pain be oh
so let's talk about that I'm into it
that's one of the signs that you're
older is that you have to predict how
quickly will I have to poop
that yeah but I I don't I don't like the
P to drunk ratio for beer no you're
right that's it's like that's another
grownup thing I got to drink six of
these and I'm peeing all night I got to
get up I was having an avatar dream and
now I got to urinate Sam Adams out of me
give me three shots of whiskey and get
me out of here exactly yeah yeah and all
yeah can't um the hangovers now I'm 42
hangovers feel like cancer yeah to me I
can't do it red wine I was into wine and
wine can't drink red wine anymore I was
going to say that's a bad hangover
liquor or now now white wine is pretty
much my jam yeah and we were watching
the World Series we were watching the
World Series and everybody's there
drinking drinking beers and I got my
civilized glass of saon Blanc yeah yeah
yeah how to say uh go socks when you're
it still has raspberry on it a finish of
raspberry anybody else want a snot of
this sa
Blanc you got a little Simo chain you're
try everyone else has
[Music]
nachos